before we continue I'd like to give a
shout out to the sponsor of this video
Shadow verse Shadow verse is a
multiplayer turn-based anime card game
with a fun-loving community of over 1
million daily players now what I liked
about this game is that the story mode
is fully voiced and you can battle
real-time opponents from around the
world using different strategies with
innovative mechanics that guarantee epic
battles start preparing for a battle of
apocalyptic proportion in shadow versus
newly released 16th card set world
uprooted which consists a set of 97
cards and two new leader cards click the
link in the description if you'd like to
check out the game and help out this
channel 2020 is the year that just keeps
on giving not too long ago I talked
about action anime that are set to debut
this year before that we look through
upcoming 2020 anime embroidered detail
and I predictably merely covered the tip
of the iceberg with those lists honestly
speaking there's just too many anime
coming out these days that having a
comprehensive list of the top shows for
an entire year is just impossible with
just 10 entries I mean it really is the
number of good anime coming out is just
overwhelming so for this video I'm gonna
focus on something that you may have
spent years or months looking forward to
sequels not much to say about sequels in
general because those of you excited to
watch them are pretty much already sold
on the first few seasons you more or
less pretty know what to expect from say
the final season of attack on Titan
after following three seasons of it
nonetheless let's talk about some of
them and build up some excitement for
this year considering how the year is
not been looking too good so far on
another note since we're in the spring
2020 season already I won't be including
titles that are set to be aired this
course such as the new season of snafu
or sword art online
to start things off we have the second
season of fire force when it was first
announced I had high hopes for fire
force it seemed to be a quartet in the
making with the creator of Soul Eater at
the helm and the mangas a fun read that
features a lot of cool and creative
powers I never expected it to blow up
like my hero academia but I was certain
that it would be here to stay when the
Kyani disaster happened my heart sank to
think that it might be gone for good
seeing as how Japan responds to
disasters in the series topic
fortunately it seemed to do well enough
for itself to warrant a sequel although
if we're gonna be technical with
everything the series was announced to
be 48 episodes at one point so this is
just a split core masquerading as a new
season similar to what they're doing
with a lot of shows these days either
way it's time for fire force fans to
rejoice after ending the previous season
with a banger of a final battle Shinra
and friends look to be back for more the
battle against the white clans continues
in the second half of the series and I'm
sure that we'll see even more amazing
battles developments and powers for the
squad as we begin the march toward the
decisive conflict let's hope that after
this second part we'll see even more
fire force instead of them going for an
anime original ending
[Music]
ix on this list is the third season of
log horizon to be honest I lost all hope
for this one you know seriously when was
the last log horizon anime and how long
ago was it when the author got caught in
the hole tax evasion fiasco you know how
real-life issues can leak into anime
production needless to say things were
looking grim for log horizon but a
miracle happened a few months ago it's
not a joke seriously a third season is
happening titled long horizon a four of
the roundtable
she Roy Akatsuki and the rest of the
gang are ready to once again take you to
the continuation on their journey in
Elder tale judging from the title it
seems that things are ready to heat up
and things aren't looking so good for
the roundtable Alliance it's great that
we're getting a new season because a lot
of things were left unanswered at the
end of the second one they also had to
stop the anime just when things were
starting to pick up if light novel
readers are to be believed
surely this new season will quench fans
five-year thirst for new log horizon and
let's hope that this is the beginning of
the series resurgence as an aside I
can't wait to see the new opening
sequence they'll pair with database this
time around among the numerous it's a
kind have come out in the past year or
two that time I got reincarnated as a
slime has been an outstanding one and
has taken off far beyond the pack thanks
to it being an izakaya that at least
starts off deviating from the norm and
presenting a refreshing take on the
genre it has become a very popular
series that could probably even give
shield hero a run for its money it's
indeed itself too many anime fans who
all waited in anticipation for the next
episode as it made its initial run I'm
not gonna spoil it for you about what I
know about the second Caesar but it
sounds like the recipe for one
rollercoaster of an arc I can also say
that it's one of the darker arcs of the
series so you better be prepared for
that I may be looking too far ahead but
for 2020s already looking awesome
the second season of slime will only
look to add to the hype for October
Varkey sequel is coming and it's ranked
seventh on this list the continuation of
one of the 90s most beloved martial arts
series has enamored a whole new
generation with its fights dramas and
thrills to be fair Bucky didn't have the
smoothest transition in terms of sequels
with its rather notable delay just not
too long ago the good news is that the
next part of the sagas being confirmed
to be coming this way who knows if
Netflix will be able to adapt the whole
saga at this rate
Netflix they've got a long way to go
with the source material spanning so
many chapters and volumes barkis quest
to become the strongest continues with
even more powerful opponents and tougher
challenges headed his way will he be
able to finally become closer to
surpassing his beast of a father wait
and see to find out sixth on the list is
the second season of doctor stone
don't look away as a favorite master of
science is about to make his imminent
return the announcement didn't take too
long and they wasted no time dropping
the bombshell on all of us just as the
first season ended sheduled for 2020
doctor stone stone walls is set to
continue the Stone Wars saga given the
poor disc sales I was a bit worried that
a second season wouldn't be greenlit but
as fate would have it the series
popularity in streaming revenues made
this happen for now we can see more of
this surprisingly educational show
that's carved a pretty good niche for
itself the past year
doctor stones really one of the more
unique shows in its execution so I'd
really recommend watching it if you
haven't done so yet it really is a
testament to how anime in general is
better than ever and despite the
detractors words anime is not creatively
bankrupt it doesn't have a specific
release date at the moment that expect
that dr. stone will return in 2020
powering its way to fifth place is the
second core of high Q to the top well
I'm not sure if I'd consider this a true
sequel because just like fire force this
is the second half of a split court
nonetheless with it being marketed as
such I'll include it on this list anyway
just when high Q's broken a seething and
surpassed all previous seasons in terms
of hype and quality we have more coming
our way
given the exciting matches and level of
animation quality that we've gotten so
far we can only expect much more out of
the second half of high Q to the top
it's actually good that we get this
break which will make sure that the
quality doesn't drop with the momentum
hike you
picked up recently it stands to win more
if it keeps the good quality up so what
can we expect more intense matches team
drama and the climactic egg to get
another excellent arc the continuation
of this season of high Q makes its way
to us this July seeing as how this
season's been going so far I only have
high hopes for the next part didn't I
say we wouldn't cover spring titles
unfortunately Subarus misfortune seems
to translate a bit too well into the
real world as the highly anticipated
second season of the blockbuster has
been tentatively delayed to July thanks
to the you know wort a it's been a
struggle and an unfortunate turn of
events on a more positive note though
absence makes the heart grow fonder and
I hope that the delay will give white
fox enough time to deliver an even
better product than what we would have
gotten anyway not much to say that
haven't already said about the second
season of re0 in the numerous previous
videos have done for the spring 2020
season the battle against the sin
Archbishop's is just beginning and we'll
see the royal selection candidates
spring into action
let's eat away for July to see the
continuation of Subarus twisted journey
in another world and number three is the
second season of the promised Neverland
yes the hit mystery thriller anime is
finally getting a second season as far
as the driving force in the show's first
season go it's being dealt with in the
few episodes given but Emma and the gang
are back for round two after the events
of season 1 there really is a lot more
to be explored in terms of the world
having finally escaped the grace-filled
house and unexplored an unknown world
lies beyond and you've got a wonder what
sorts of danger awaits the children
after all a doubt we've seen the last of
those demons these kids have been
through hell and back so I'm not worried
in the slightest for them whatever
challenges await them they'll surely be
able to take them head-on if you still
haven't seen this anime I highly
recommend you do so it was definitely
one of the best anime of 2019 the next
installment of the popular dark thriller
series hits our screens this October
[Music]
so who hasn't heard of Demon Slayer the
supernatural action series took the
world by storm for a good part of 2019
and it hasn't looked back since
given its record-breaking numbers in
manga sales and it's unprecedented rise
to stardom a sequel is obviously on its
way what I didn't see coming is that its
sequel would take the form of a movie
that's right the continuation to the
demon slayer anime is going to be a
movie and it will chronicle the infinity
train arc a short arc the features are
mostly self-contained story it will
introduce some new characters as well as
show us the might of the upper moons
with the party's first major battle
against one of them what challenges
await tangier oh and the party when they
take the ride and enter the world of
endless dreams mark your calendars a
cape once the third heavens filled
movies done with I'm sure that UFO table
will be placing the announcement of this
movie's release at the top of their
priority list now what else could outdo
Demon Slayer as the top sequel in 2020
that we should be all excited for well
you see before Demon Slayer there was
one other anime that took the world by
storm and in much much greater effect
than it did
[Music]
before demon slayers popularity allowed
it to explode into the mainstream last
year there was attack on titan nothing
after it can be compared to how it
pioneered the exploding popularity of
anime into the mainstream not one punch
man not my hero academia and certainly
not demon slayer therefore it's a shouid
that the most hyped and top sequel this
2020 is the final season of attack on
titan it's been a long seven years full
of waiting spin-offs and other
developments but we're now finally going
to be able to see the ending of this
grand tale in just a few more months i
mean in its storied run attack on titan
has evolved from merely a gritty
survival series to one that tackles more
unorthodox topics like politics how will
this long-running epic finally come to
an end for people who don't read the
manga there's only one way to find out
adding to the log jam that's the
star-studded month of october twenty
twenty at a con titan will be sure to
spearhead all those hype sequels that we
all wait and here I was thinking that
April was going to be the blockbuster
season of the year with so many sequels
to look forward to this 2020 I advise
you all to sit tight hang on and get
through this as we've got a lot of great
sequels headed our way
which among these sequels are you
looking forward to the most I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the comments
section as with other videos make sure
to give the video a like and hit the
subscribe button if you enjoyed it don't
forget to check out our sponsors game
Shadow verse the links in the
description more anime goodness is
coming your way soon but that's got to
do it for this video so I'll see you
next time on Vinnie tube
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]